.
Wasser - der Ursprung allen Lebens.
Wasser - die Lebensader der Erde.
Wasser ist ihre Leidenschaft.
Wunderschön!
Sie übernehmen Verantwortung.
Sie sammelten den Müll von sich aus
ein. Das ist erfreulich.
Und sie kümmern sich.
Das ist ein Traum!
Damit sie eine Zukunft haben.
Unsere Wasserwelten.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Entspannte Musik *
Im indonesischen Tauchparadies
Raja Ampat
liegt das Dorf Sawinggrai.
120 Menschen leben hier.
Über die Hälfte davon sind Kinder.
Ihr Lehrer ist Glarner.
Wenn wir fischen gehen,
woran müssen wir dann denken?
Nicht auf die Korallen stehen.
- Schnorcheln.
Den Abfall mitnehmen.
Richtig. Damit wir das nicht
vergessen, haben wir unser Memory.
Wer weiss es noch?
Wie viele Fische
sind in der Kategorie grün?
90.
Jonas Müller arbeitete in der Schweiz
als Betriebsökonom.
Vor fünf Jahren hängte er
seine Karriere an den Nagel,
lernte Indonesisch
und baute sein Lernzentrum
für Umweltschutz und Ökologie auf.
Wir spielen ein Memory,
das ich selbst gemacht habe.
Es ist in drei Gruppen unterteilt:
grün bedeutet,
dass es von diesem Fisch viele gibt
und man ihn guten Gewissens
essen kann.
Orange bedeutet,
der Fisch ist gefährdet,
man sollte lieber
einen anderen fangen.
Rot heisst, der Fisch
ist stark bedroht und damit tabu.
Saltwater crocodile.
Mit seinem Lernzentrum
springt Jonas in eine Bresche
denn das Niveau der
staatlichen Schulen ist sehr tief.
Hier jedoch lernen die Kinder
spielerisch und nachhaltig.
Es hat diverse Lerneffekte.
Einerseits sollen sie ihre eigene
Sprache aufrechterhalten können.
Das Spiel ist in Englisch
und in der einheimischen Sprache.
Sie lernen also
die englischen Namen der Fische,
was wichtig ist für den Tourismus.
Und sie lernen die Namen
in ihrer einheimischen Sprache
und auch,
welche Fische sie fangen können.
Am Mittag setzt Jonas das Gelernte
mit den Kindern in die Tat um.
* Entspannte Musik *
Jonas Müller lebt in Indonesien
in Südostasien.
Bei West-Papua
liegt das Tauchparadies Raja Ampat.
Etwas abseits und vom Tourismus
noch weitgehend verschont,
findet sich das Dorf Sawinggrai.
Hier führt Jonas Müller
seine Umweltschule.
Ich interessierte mich schon in
der Schweiz sehr für Umweltthemen.
Als ich dann hierherkam und die
unglaubliche Schönheit der Natur,
aber auch die ganzen Gefahren
gesehen habe,
wurde das Bedürfnis
noch viel stärker,
mich dafür zu engagieren.
So ist es nach und nach
entstanden.
Jetzt geht Jonas mit seinen Schülern
speerfischen.
Fisch ist die tägliche Nahrung
der Einheimischen.
Er wird immer
frisch aus dem Meer geholt.
Stopp!
Kinder, schwimmt nur in der Gruppe.
Arno, zuhören!
Wir gehen da rüber speerfischen.
Und schiesst nie
in die Richtung eurer Freunde.
* Entspannte Musik *
Wasser ist auch die Welt
von Adelrich Uhr -
schon von Berufs wegen.
Er ist Klärwerksmeister der Abwasser-
reinigungsanlage Küsnacht-Erlenbach.
Auch privat ist Wasser seine Passion.
Heute will er im Zürichsee
nach verschollenen Schätzen tauchen.
Ich packe mein Tauchmaterial
für den heutigen Tauchgang
zum Wrack,
das wir im April
bei Stäfa gefunden haben.
Wir absolvieren heute
den 23. Tauchgang.
Wir erhoffen uns natürlich
weitere Funde.
Das ist die zweite Lampe, die wir
auf dem Wrack gefunden haben.
Das ist eine Backbord-Lampe.
Ausserdem haben wir einen
Ringschlüssel aus dem Motorenraum.
Dann haben wir einen Schuh gefunden,
der unter dem Schlamm vergraben war.
Wir holten ihn dann hervor.
Wir vermuten, dass der Schuh
von einem Matrosen stammt,
der auf dem Schiff war
und mit ihm unterging.
Wir suchen die Geschichte immer noch
in der Dokumentation der "Zürichsee
Zeitung" und im "NZZ"-Archiv.
Aber wir haben
bis heute nichts gefunden.
Aber der 58-jährige Hobbyunterwasser-
archäologe gibt nicht auf.
Obwohl er schon über 300 Std.
im Archiv verbracht hat -
zusammen mit den Kollegen
vom Tauchclub Swiss Archeodivers.
Hallo zusammen!
- (Alle) Hallo!
Adelrich Uhr ist im Tauchclub bekannt
wie ein bunter Hund.
Alle nennen ihn nur Agi.
Als Mitglied aufgenommen wird nur,
wer einen Kurs in
Unterwasserarchäologie bestanden hat.
Hoi, Roy.- Morgen, Agi. Alles klar?
- Alles gut.
Tschau, Adrian.- Geht's dir gut?
- Röbeli. Beno.- Hoi.
Hört mal her,
es gibt eine Besprechung.
Wir waren jetzt
22-mal unter Wasser.
Auf den ersten
drei bis vier Tauchgängen
konnten wir Relikte heraufholen.
Heute gibt es eine Abräumaktion.
Markus und ich gehen zuerst runter
und messen erneut den Motorraum aus.
Dann werden wir
einen Teil des Schuhs suchen,
der noch
irgendwo dort unten rumliegt.
In 20 Min. sind alle komplett
ausgerüstet auf dem Schiff.
Ist das für alle realistisch?
- Ja.- Auf dem Schiff?
Die Hobbyforscher
untersuchen das Wrack
mit der Einwilligung
der Kantonsarchäologie.
Darum dokumentieren sie
jeden Schritt.
Vor jedem Tauchgang
liegt Spannung in der Luft.
Du bist wirklich
wie ein kleiner Lausbub,
der sucht, macht und tut.
Plötzlich hörst du,
dass da etwas ist.
Dann suchst du.
Und dann findest du etwas.
Schatzsuche - ein Bubentraum.
Man kann es nicht anders sagen.
Kann das Team dem versunkenen Schiff
noch mehr Geheimnisse entlocken?
Gibt das Wrack heute
den zweiten Matrosenschuh frei?
Die Erwartung ist hoch.
(Jonas) One, two, three, go!
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Unterwasserwelt von Raja Ampat
ist eine der schönsten überhaupt.
Während eines Tauchgangs kann man
bis zu 300 Fischarten entdecken.
Die Jungen fischen
mit einem Speer und einem Gummiband.
Die Technik
lernen sie schon von klein auf.
Jetzt können sie umsetzen,
was sie am Morgen gelernt haben.
Sie wissen:
Die raren Tiere, die im Memoryspiel
rot und orange markiert waren,
sollen verschont bleiben.
Dazu gehören auch Wasserschildkröten.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Jonas) On the front!
Dieser Junge
hat einen Soldatenfisch erwischt.
Oft haben wir eine Machete dabei,
mit der wir dem Fisch auf den Kopf
schlagen, falls er noch lebt.
Dann ist er auch tot.
Ich habe sie dazu angehalten,
denn sie haben
keinen Bezug zum Tier,
es würde ihnen nie leid tun,
es könnte noch so zappeln.
Ich finde, man sollte es schnell
von den Qualen erlösen.
Jonas fischt mit einer Harpune,
die er selber gemacht hat.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ihm ist es wichtig,
dass alle nur so viel fischen,
wie sie auf einmal essen können.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Prusten *
Es ist ein Kaninchenfisch.
Einige Fische sind gefährlich.
Man muss sehr gut aufpassen, weil
die Stacheln des Fischs giftig sind.
Das Gift ist zwar nicht tödlich,
aber wenn das jetzt
an meinen Finger gelangen würde,
wäre dieser etwa 30 Min. lang
gelähmt.
Die schlimmste Verletzung war,
als ich
auf einen Blauring-Oktopus trat.
Es ist eines der giftigsten Tiere
der Welt.
Er biss mich in den Zeh. Innerhalb
von 2 Min. war ich komplett gelähmt.
Das Gift
ist in 99 % der Fälle tödlich.
Ich hatte Glück, dass die Einhei-
mischen sehr schnell reagierten
mit Feuer und ihren Blättern etc.
Wobei alle westlichen Ärzte sagen,
das habe nichts gebracht.
Aber es gibt weltweit
kein Gegengift für Tetrodotoxin.
Die Behandlung,
die sie gemacht haben,
kann nicht falsch gewesen sein,
denn ich habe ja überlebt.
Ich musste mir
einen Zeh amputieren lassen,
da er begann, sich aufzulösen.
Ich liess ihn mir
in der Schweiz amputieren.
Aufgeben und in der Schweiz bleiben
war für Jonas nie eine Option.
Zu wichtig sind ihm
die Kinder von Raja Ampat.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Auf dem Zürichsee bei Stäfa
sind Agi Uhr und sein Team gespannt,
was der Tauchgang
zum versunkenen Schiffswrack bringt.
Obwohl er schon über 1'000 Tauchgänge
im See gemacht hat,
ist es auch für Agi
jedes Mal ein neues Abenteuer.
Sein Tauchbuddy Markus Inglin
macht Unterwasseraufnahmen,
um das Wrack zu dokumentieren.
Der Rest des Teams
folgt erst später nach.
So wird
möglichst wenig Schlick aufgewirbelt.
In 22 m Tiefe liegt es da:
das Wrack eines Ledischiffes.
Ein über 100 Jahre altes
Transportschiff,
gefertigt aus massivem Tannenholz.
Auf seiner letzten Fahrt um 1910
transportierte das Schiff Sand -
vielleicht
für eine Baustelle in Zürich.
Agi und sein Team fanden heraus,
dass es mit dem Heck voran versank.
Die Wucht
riss das Dach des Motorenraumes weg.
Was hat das Schiff
zum Kentern gebracht?
Ein Sturm? Ein Leck?
Agi vermisst den Motorenraum
und findet einen kleinen Gegenstand.
Der gelernte Maschinenmechaniker
will sich den genauer ansehen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf den Seychellen
hat die Bernerin Ornella Weideli
den vielleicht schönsten Arbeitsweg
der Welt.
Die Forscherin
kommt immer wieder hierher,
um mehr Erkenntnisse
für ihre Doktorarbeit über Junghaie
zu gewinnen.
Hier auf der Seychelleninsel D'Arros
betreibt die Schweizer Stiftung
Save Our Seas ein Forschungslabor,
finanziert
von einem saudischen Mäzen.
Ornella bereitet eine Exkursion vor.
Unterstützt wird sie
vom wissenschaftlichen Leiter
der Stiftung, Ryan Daly.
Könntest du
den anderen Haken befestigen?
Er liegt dort
beim Kabelbinder und der Schere.
Haie zu sehen und mit ihnen
zu schwimmen, ist das eine.
Das macht extrem Spass. Tauchen
und Schnorcheln ist das Schönste.
Aber es macht auch grossen Spass,
sie zu fangen, von Nahem zu sehen
und sie zu spüren. Mit ihnen
zu interagieren ist übertrieben.
Aber sie ausmessen und
genauer anschauen, das macht Spass.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir sind auf den Seychellen
im Indischen Ozean.
Sie bestehen aus 115 Inseln.
D'Arros ist eine davon.
Gerade mal 30 Menschen wohnen hier.
Das Saint-Joseph-Atoll ist
20 Bootsminuten von D'Arros entfernt.
Auf der Überfahrt
müssen Ornella und ihr Team
einen 70 m tiefen Kanal überwinden.
Hier, wo wir jetzt durchfahren,
ist der einzige Eingang ins Atoll,
wo wir mit dem Boot reinkommen.
Hier wird es ganz flach.
Wir sehen es gleich.
Hier wechselt es.
Wenn wir schneller fahren würden,
wäre der Motor zu weit unten.
Ryan muss jetzt gut aufpassen.
Hier sieht man Korallenköpfe, die
aus dem Wasser ragen, coral bommies.
Ryan muss aufpassen,
dass er nicht in so einen reinfährt.
Aber er ist bereits so oft hier
reingefahren ... Dort ist etwas!
Eine Schildkröte.
Nein, ah ja, there you go.
Two!
Da sind wieder
zwei, drei, vier Schildkröten.
Ebenfalls weit verbreitet
sind Stachelrochen.
Hier vorne haben wir jeweils Glück
mit den Haien.
Wir schauen dort,
ob wir einige finden.
Aber es ist
momentan noch sehr, sehr flach.
Wir haben herausgefunden, dass sie
bei nicht sehr hoher Flut hier sind.
Einfach aus Beobachtungen.
Manchmal kann man sie bereits sehen,
wenn man von oben schaut.
Einer ...
* Entspannte Musik *
Die Kinder von Raja Ampat
sind hungrig vom Speerfischen.
Jetzt freuen sie sich
auf ihren selbst gefangenen Fisch.
Sie sind zu klein.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Was ist das Problem,
wenn wir zu kleine Fische fangen?
Die konnten sich
noch nicht vermehren.
Genau, und dann haben wir hier
irgendwann keine Fische mehr.
Wir müssen also Geduld haben,
bis wir sie essen.
Und doch: Wie im Unterricht gelernt,
haben die Kinder
die gefährdeten Fische verschont.
Das Gute ist, dass es nur Fische
aus dem grünen Bereich sind. Super.
Es sind aber diverse Fische dabei,
die zu klein sind.
Sein Ökologieunterricht
hat Wirkung gezeigt,
denn früher war es anders.
Sie sind auf die Korallen getreten
und haben alles rausgeholt,
das sie schnappen konnten.
Vorher haben sie eine Schildkröte
gesehen, die hätten sie auch geholt.
Aber mittlerweile wissen sie auch,
dass die Schildkröte einerseits
sehr wichtig für das Riff
und andererseits
ein Touristenmagnet ist.
Jetzt holen sie sie nur noch
für grosse Feste. Sonst nicht mehr.
Das Essen
wird gemeinschaftlich geteilt.
In der Schweiz
ernährte sich Jonas vegan.
Hier lebt der 28-Jährige wie die
Einheimischen von Fisch und Reis -
tagein, tagaus.
* Fröhliches indonesisches Lied *
Bei diesem Spiel müssen sie heraus-
finden, welches Tier jemand ist.
Sie singen:
"Welches Tier bin ich?"
Sie machen entsprechende Bewegungen
und die anderen müssen antworten.
* Fröhlicher Gesang *
Sie geben einander
natürlich nie recht.
Wenn die eine Gruppe eigentlich
recht hat, sagen sie: "Nein, nein!"
Okay, one, two, three!
* Schreien und Lachen *
* Ruhige Musik *
* Jubelruf *
Das ist die Zündkerze!
Wie es aussieht,
ist es ein Vierzylindermotor.
Schon ein grösserer.
Ich kann noch nicht sagen, ob es
ein Petrol- oder Benzinmotor ist,
aber es ist sicher ein starker
Motor, der später eingebaut wurde.
Es ist geil,
dass wir das gefunden haben.
Das ist ein wichtiges Indiz.
So.
Der leidenschaftliche
Hobby-Unterwasserarchäologe Agi Uhr
weiss jetzt mit einiger Sicherheit,
dass das Schiff
erst nach 1910 gesunken ist.
So? Hätten wir das.
Super. Hast du die Kerze gesehen?
- Ja.
Die ist wirklich
von einem Vierzylinder.- Ja.
Es kommt jetzt nach über 100 Jahren
zum ersten Mal an die Oberfläche.
Mal schauen, was dran ist.
Agis Tauchkollegen schicken
weitere Fundgegenstände herauf -
mit dem Segen der Kantonsarchäologie.
Das sind Sachen aus dem Motorenraum.
Das ist ein Teil des Kamins,
den wir heute noch bargen.
Wie das genau funktioniert,
weiss ich auch nicht.
Es ist ein schweres Teil.
Aber es stammt vom Kamin.
Dann haben wir hier ...
... auch einen Teil des Kamins.
Wir wollen
die Russpartikel abkratzen
und auch schauen, was es ist.
Da hatte es wieder einen Silch
von einem Fischer dran.
Ich weiss von ca. 15 Wracks,
darunter ziemlich grosse.
Ich lese ja die alten Zeitungen
von 1845 bis 1900.
Ich suche dort nach Einträgen
von versunkenen Schiffen.
Dort liest man immer wieder über
Schiffer, die besoffen herumrasten.
Das war ein Lohnbestandteil,
Alkohol.
Und die waren wirklich
auch stark alkoholisiert.
Wahrscheinlich konnten sie
nur schon deshalb nicht schwimmen.
Wenn mal einer ausrutschte, sank er
mit seinen vollgesogenen Kleidern.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Dieses Projekt ist nun abgeschlossen.
Aber Agi weiss: auf dem Seegrund
warten noch viele weitere Rätsel
darauf, gelöst zu werden.
Priis!
- Priis!
Im Saint-Joseph-Atoll
auf dem Seychellen
brennt die Sonne
mit voller Wucht vom Himmel,
denn wir sind ganz nah am Äquator.
Hier erforscht Ornella Weideli
junge Zitronen-
und Schwarzspitzen-Riffhaie.
Gehst du zu Ryan?
Dann bewegen wir uns
entlang der Sandbank.
Im Moment sehen wir dort hinten
mehrere Haie.
Es ist sehr einfach,
Zitronenhaie zu erkennen,
denn beide Rückenflossen
haben dieselbe Grösse.
Wenn zwei rausstehen,
so gelblich, bräunlich,
ist es immer ein Zitronenhai.
Beim Schwarzspitzen-Riffhai
sieht man immer nur
die erste Rückenflosse.
Die Bernerin forscht hier
seit vier Jahren.
Ryan Daly, der lokale
wissenschaftliche Direktor,
hilft ihr dabei.
Wurde er schon mal gefangen?
Er ist neu. Ein Zitronenhai,
ein kleines Männchen.
Ein Männchen,
also ein N wie Nadja.
Der junge Zitronenhai
wird mit einem Chip versehen,
so erkennt ihn das Team
bei einem erneuten Fang wieder.
Dann kontrollieren wir
die Chipnummer:
2-1-7-6-9.
- 2-1-7-6-9.
Das Hauptziel ist,
besser zu verstehen,
was die Tiere essen,
wie es ihnen geht,
wie viel sie wachsen, wie weit sie
in den ersten Jahren gehen.
Einige Haie sahen wir
während drei Jahren immer hier.
Später haben wir sie
dort hinten und hier wiedergefunden.
Sie gehen also
500 bis 1'000 m weg.
Und solche Daten sind natürlich
sehr wichtig für den Schutz.
Wenn man weiss,
dass die Haie im Atoll bleiben,
kann man es schützen und
damit auch die Jungzeit der Haie.
Das ist natürlich perfekt.
Ausgewachsene Zitronenhaie
können über 3 m lang
und bis zu 30 Jahre alt werden.
Okay, 49,3.
55,1.
63,1.
Jetzt nehmen wir
noch eine DNA-Probe.
Dem Jungtier wird ein winziger Teil
der Rückenflosse abgeschnitten.
Anhand der DNA kann so der Ver-
wandtschaftsgrad zwischen den Tieren
rekonstruiert werden.
Hier habe ich das Privileg, dass ich
etwas von Grund auf aufbauen konnte.
Diese Haie hier
wurden nie vorher gefangen.
Und als Biologin
macht das natürlich sehr viel Spass,
wenn man einfach hingehen
und schauen kann, was da ist.
Bei der Arbeit hier
gibt es nur das Meer und die Haie.
Das ist ein unglaubliches Gefühl.
Man kann immer seltener
an Orten arbeiten,
wo man
nicht mit Menschen in Kontakt ist.
* Ruhige Musik *
* Fröhliches indonesisches Lied *
Seit drei Jahren
ist die Umweltschule in Raja Ampat
für den Schweizer Jonas Müller
Heimat und Herzensangelegenheit.
Okay, wir haben hier
ein tolles Buch,
in dem es um den Plastikabfall
in Raja Ampat geht.
Dieses Buch ist extra
für Raja Ampat gemacht.
Man sieht auf den Bildern gut,
dass wirklich Raja Ampat
dargestellt wird.
D.h., die Kinder haben einen
sehr hohen Wiedererkennungswert.
Hier sieht man z.B die Mantas,
was ja auch
sehr für Raja Ampat spricht.
Das Buch erzählt die Geschichte
zweier Kinder, die lernen,
dass Plastik ein Abfallproblem ist.
Der 28-jährige Glarner
ist hierher gekommen,
um die Natur zu schützen und die
Kinder dafür zu sensibilisieren.
(Indonesisch) Hört zu,
wenn jemand eine Geschichte erzählt,
müsst ihr euch konzentrieren.
Nicht einfach dasitzen,
den Wind geniessen und relaxen.
Verstanden?
(Alle) Ja.
- Bildet jetzt bitte Gruppen.
Jonas
ist passionierter Umweltschützer.
Seine Ziele
will er über die Kinder erreichen.
Ich möchte ihnen zeigen
dass es sich lohnt,
sich für diese wunderschöne Natur
einzusetzen,
denn sie wird ihnen
viel zurückgeben.
Sie sind hier so stark von der Natur
abhängig wie sonst kaum jemand.
Warum will sie das essen?
Wer hat das im Buch gesehen?
(Alle) Novi.
Er hat Angst,
dass die Schildkröte was macht?
(Alle) Es isst.
Was will sie essen?
- (Alle) Plastik.
Es wurde in den letzten zwei, drei
Jahren zu einem sehr grossen Thema.
Es hat einerseits mit dem
aufkommenden Tourismus zu tun,
aber es ist leider weltweit ein
grosses Problem, v.a. in Indonesien.
Und das Verständnis bei der lokalen
Bevölkerung ist noch gar nicht da.
Als ich angefangen habe,
war es für sie egal,
ob am Strand ein Stöckchen
oder Plastikflasche liegt.
Es geht also zuerst einmal darum,
Verständnis aufzubauen,
weshalb es ein Problem ist
und was sie dagegen tun können.
Ich versuche,
sie dabei zu unterstützen.
Okay, wer ist in Gruppe 3?
Gut, das ist für euch.
* Entspannte Musik *
Auf den Seychellen erforscht
die Bernerin Ornella Weideli
junge Zitronenhaie
und Schwarzspitzen-Riffhaie.
An einigen Orten der Welt
sind diese gefährdet.
Doch hier
bietet ihnen das Atoll Schutz
und sie sind weit verbreitet.
1 kg.
- 1 kg.
Oh, ein Bissiger!
Zitronenhaie lassen nicht los,
wenn sie einmal etwas im Maul haben.
Deshalb ist es ziemlich gefährlich,
wenn sie einen beissen.
Die meisten Leute ziehen
reflexartig die Hand weg.
Wenn aber nur ein Finger im Maul
ist, lässt man ihn besser drin,
denn irgendwann lassen sie los.
Nachdem Ornella und ihr Team die
Tiere vermessen und gechippt haben,
entlassen sie sie wieder
in die Freiheit.
Jetzt haben wir wieder einen.
- Ein Zitronenhai?- Ja.
Zitronenhaie können
in ihren eigenen Schwanz beissen.
Sie sind sehr flexibel. Deshalb muss
man gut auf seine Fingern aufpassen.
Es blutet extrem, wenn sie
einen in den Finger beissen.
Hast du gesehen,
wie er zugeschnappt hat?
Das ist einer, den wir
schon mal gefangen haben.
Als Ryan ihn rausnahm,
sah er bereits,
dass hier ein kleiner Teil
der Flosse fehlt.
Normalerweise
ist sie so spitzig wie hier,
aber ein kleiner Teil fehlt.
Deshalb wissen wir, dass wir
ihn schon mal gefangen haben.
Wir wissen aber noch nicht,
ob das 2015, 2016 oder 2014 war.
Das können wir
in der Database nachschauen.
Wir machen jetzt genau dasselbe:
Wir vermessen und wiegen sie.
Wir haben GPS und können schauen,
wo er letztes Mal war,
wie viel er gewachsen ist usw.
Dank diesen Informationen wissen
wir, wie es den Tieren hier geht.
Die Rückenflosse
des Schwarzspitzen-Riffhais
ist
wie ein individueller Fingerabdruck.
Dank ihm und den Daten im Chip können
die Forscher das Tier wiedererkennen.
51,6 und 61,6.
Wir lassen ihn frei.
Es ist schon 17.50 Uhr.
Die Angst, die wir Menschen
vorHaien haben, ist völlig absurd.
die Haie
sollten vor uns Angst haben,
denn wir Töten so viele Haie.
laut Schätzungen
sind es 70 bis 100 Mio. pro Jahr.
Umgekehrt
wurden in den letzten Jahren
etwa fünf Leute von Haien
angegriffen oder sogar getötet.
Das ist nichts, wenn man bedenkt,
wie viele Menschen
täglich im Meer baden oder surfen.
Die Situation ist also traurig,
denn die Haie sind sehr bedroht.
Das Problem ist,
dass sie von grossen Fischerbooten
als Beifang gefangen werden.
Viele Fische
kann man problemlos essen,
weil sie sich schnell wieder
fortpflanzen.
Aber viele Haie haben nur einmal
pro Jahr ein, zwei oder drei Junge.
Das ist nichts,
wenn man bedenkt,
wie stark wir den Bestand
beschädigen. Das gibt zu denken.
Die Ausbeute des Tages ist gut,
das Team konnte
gleich mehrere Tiere markieren.
Aber jetzt ist es Zeit
für den Rückweg,
denn hier, nahe am Äquator,
geht die Sonne
innerhalb weniger Minuten unter.
* Entspannte Musik *
Zwölf Flugstunden von den Seychellen
entfernt, in der Schweiz,
hat soeben das neue Jahr begonnen.
In Zürich weht ein eisiger Wind.
Was fehlt noch?
- Ich weiss nicht.
Becher und so.
- Braucht's noch etwas?
Becher.
Ja, Becher.
Der Wind bläst sie sicher weg.
Der Tauchclub Zürichsee,
dessen Präsident Agi Uhr ist,
trifft sich
zum alljährlichen Neujahrsanlass.
Mit Tochter Tanja
hat er schon frühmorgens
Bouillon und Glühwein zubereitet.
Wir machen heute
den ersten Tauchgang des Jahres.
Das beginnt natürlich
früh im neuen Jahr.
Der 1. Januar eignet sich nicht,
weil da niemand ganz nüchtern ist.
Deshalb treffen wir uns seit
22 Jahren regelmässig am 2. Januar -
so habe ich es
im Jahresbericht gelesen.
Das Wasser der Limmat beim Zürcher
Bauschänzli ist nichts für Feiglinge,
es misst gerade mal 4 °C.
Die Taucher springen bei der Mole
rein, tauchen ums Bauschänzli rum
und kommen hier wieder raus.
Weil es keine hat
andere Ausstiegmöglichkeit hat,
müssen wir die Leiter selber setzen.
Die leidenschaftlichen Hobbytaucher
haben schon so Einiges
aus der Limmat gefischt -
vom gestohlenen Tresor
bis zum künstlichen Gebiss.
Was hast du schon gefunden?
U.a. ein Goldkettchen
und eine schwimmende Zwanzigernote.
Anders haben wir gesehen,
aber nicht raufgeholt:
Einkaufswagen, Fahrräder ...
- Die waren zu schwer?
Ja, das tun wir uns
auf unserem Tauchgang nicht an.
Das holen wir eher an einer unserer
Limmat-Säuberungsaktionen rauf.
Bestens, Agi.
- Gut tauch!- Viel Spass.
Kommt etwas näher,
damit ich nicht so schreien muss.
Ich möchte alle herzlich
beim Tauchclub Zürichsee begrüssen
zum Neujahrstauchen,
das wir jedes Jahr veranstalten.
Der Einstieg ist auf dieser Rampe.
Hier könnt ihr rein, abtauchen,
in der Mitte des Sees durch.
Laut einer neuen Auflage dürfen wir
nicht mehr auf die andere Seite.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
wie gut ihr im Kompasstauchen seid.
* Lachen *
Es geht nicht darum, das Bauschänzli
von Unrat zu befreien.
Vielmehr nimmt jeder
einen bis zwei Gegenstände raus -
es kann auch ein Fahrrad sein.
* Lachen *
Gut, dann: Gut tauch!
- Genau.
Der offizielle Tauchergruss
ist allerdings existenzieller.
Gut Luft!
Dass man immer genügend Luft hat
unter Wasser.
Das ist eigentlich
der einzige Spruch: Gut Luft!
Agi und seine Tochter Tanja
sind gespannt darauf,
was sie im kühlen Wasser erwartet.
Gut?
- Ja.
* Ruhige Musik *
Die Kinder der indonesischen
Tauchregion Raja Ampat
sind voller Eifer bei der Sache.
Sie machen Beach Cleaning
und reinigen den Strand vom Abfall,
den die Strömung angeschwemmt hat.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
In nur 20 Min.
kommt einiges zusammen,
v.a. Plastik.
Die Kids füllen fünf grosse Säcke.
* Jonas spricht indonesisch. *
Was ist das Problem
mit diesem Abfall?
Die Kügelchen
bleiben im Hals stecken.
Ja, denn im Wasser
sieht das aus wie?
(Alle) Plankton!
Plankton. Und der Manta?
- Isst es.
Was passiert?
- Er stirbt.
Okay, hier wirft jemand
ein Papiertaschentuch ins Meer.
Wie lange dauert es,
bis es abgebaut ist?
Einen Monat.
Wie lange dauert es bei einer
Plastiktüte?- (Alle) 20 Jahre.
Was frisst die Schildkröte im Buch?
- Plastik.
Und was dachte sie, dass sie frisst?
- Eine Qualle.- Eine Qualle.
Schildkröten fressen Plastik.
Wale, Delfine, Mantas -
alle unsere Freunde im Meer
können daran sterben.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass immer mehr hängen bleibt.
Wenn sie im Meer Abfall sehen,
holen sie ihn raus.
Sie sagen oft von sich aus:
"Dort sieht es nicht schön aus,
komm, wir räumen auf."
Oder wenn sie schnorcheln, sammeln
sie von sich aus den Abfall auf.
Die Kinder machen
sehr erfreuliche Fortschritte.
Es ist ein Anfang.
Aber das gigantische Abfallproblem
können Jonas und die Kinder
nicht alleine lösen.
Wir trennen den Abfall
sortieren alles aus,
was wir verbrennen können.
Für leichtes Plastik
gibt es leider keine bessere Lösung.
Man müsste es sonst mit dem Flugzeug
nach Singapur schicken,
was auch nicht sinnvoll ist.
Wir passen auf,
dass die Kinder keinen Rauch
von Plastikabfall einatmen,
weil der sehr gefährlich ist.
Nur eine professionelle
Abfallentsorgung
kann die Umwelt nachhaltig schützen.
Jonas hat eine Vision:
Das Ziel wäre,
dass es eines Tages eine richtige
Abfallsammelstelle in Wasai gibt,
dem Hauptort von Raja Ampat.
Dann müsste man
ein grösseres Boot organisieren,
das z.B. zweimal pro Monat
bei jedem Dorf vorbeifährt.
Es würde in Raja Ampat herumfahren,
den ganzen Abfall einsammeln
und diesen nach Wasai bringen.
Dort müsste der Abfall
unter korrekten Bedingungen
behandelt bzw. verbrannt werden.
Wenn man das bis in zwei Jahren
realisieren könnte,
wäre das genial
und für Raja Ampat extrem wichtig.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Eindringliche Töne *
Auch am Grund der Limmat hinterlässt
die moderne Zivilisation ihre Spuren.
Mitten in Zürich, beim Bauschänzli,
entdecken Agi und Tanja so einiges.
* Beklemmende Töne *
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf den Seychellen ist die 32-jährige
Haiforscherin Ornella Weideli
nach der gestrigen Exkursion
schon früh auf den Beinen.
Jetzt will sie im Labor die Daten
für ihre Doktorarbeit auswerten.
Gestern haben wir die Haie
Nr. 700, 701 und 702 gefangen.
702.
Okay, der wurde
bereits einmal gefangen -
und zwar am 5. Oktober 2017.
Es ist noch nicht sehr lange her,
ein halbes Jahr,
und war in der Zone B.
Gestern war er in Zone A.
Das sind zwischen 500 und 1'000 m.
Sie gehen nicht weit.
Dann kann ich schauen,
wie viel er gewachsen ist.
Er ist 4,2 cm gewachsen.
Er hat aber abgenommen.
Z.T. haben wir Neugeborene,
die richtig dick sind.
Die sind voll.
Beim ersten Mal fragten wir uns,
weshalb sie so voll sind.
Der Grund ist ihre Leber,
die sehr, sehr gross ist,
die vollgestopft ist
mit Fettreserven der Mutter.
Jetzt ist ein halbes Jahr vorbei,
er hat die Energie der Leber
in seinen Körper aufgenommen,
ist aber gleichzeitig gewachsen.
Wir wissen: Es geht ihm gut.
Es ist typisch,
dass der Umfang zurückgeht.
Ich gebe noch die anderen drei ein,
die wir gestern gefangen haben.
An der Limmat
zieht der Tauchclub Zürichsee
allerlei Trophäen an Land.
Gegenstände,
die mit oder ohne Absicht
auf dem Grund des Flusses landeten.
Ha! Laptop.
Achtung! Den Humpen habe ich nicht.
- Nein.
Unten.
- Kriegst du es hier hoch?
Es fährt noch.- Hinten hat es
noch Luft. Du könntest rumfahren.
Frauenhandtaschen
sind unergründlich tief.
Ein Brillenetui, ID.
So kann man es zuordnen,
wenn wir eine ID haben.
Das Handy ist
natürlich auch nicht mehr so ...
Kopfhörer
und diverser kleiner Krimskrams.
Die Auto- und Hausschlüssel
wird sie auch suchen.
Wertgegenstände werden die Taucher
der Polizei übergeben.
Das Übrige, ohne Besitzer und Wert,
wird fachgerecht entsorgt.
Schau mal, alles!
Laptop, Telefon, Natel, Humpen.
Messer.
Sonnenbrille.
Irgendwo habe ich noch ein Handy.
- Da hinten.
iPhone.
Samsung.
Ja.
Es ist traurig, dass solche Sachen
hier reingeschmissen werden.
Ich weiss auch nicht ...
Gerade ein Laptop -
das ist der zweite oder dritte,
den wir in den letzten Jahren
rausgeholt haben.
Ein iPhone kann leicht -
nicht direkt aus der Hand fallen -,
aber wenn man so macht, fliegt es
weg.- Pass mit dem Messer auf!
Es ist traurig,
dass man alles reinschmeisst.
Aha! Ein Portemonnaie.
Ohne Geld drin.
Dann eine Uhr.
Mit Schloss.
Was ist die letzte Vignette?
Seit vier Jahren
kommt Ornella Weideli
regelmässig
auf die Forschungsinsel D'Arros.
Ein Teil der Region
steht unter Schutz.
Ornella taucht ab, um zu schauen,
wie es um die Wasserwelt steht.
Wir gehen nach Tippers,
einem wunderschönen Tauchplatz
am Riffrand des Saint-Joseph-Atolls.
Sehr bekannt für Schildkröten
und Schwarzspitzen-Riffhaie.
Die Schweizer Stiftung Save Our Seas
finanziert ihre Doktorarbeit mit.
CEO Michael Scholl
engagiert sich dafür,
dass auch die Region um D'Arros
unter Schutz gestellt wird.
Schon nach kurzer Zeit
wird das Team von Haien begleitet.
Es sind neugierige,
intelligente Tiere.
Geschützte Orte wie diese Höhle
bieten zahlreichen Fischen
Unterschlupf.
Der grosse Fledermausfisch
kennt keine Scheu.
Immer wieder nähert er sich
den beiden Tauchenden.
Etwas skeptischer
zeigt sich der Zackenbarsch.
Grüne Meeresschildkröten
sind in dieser Gegend
seit über 20 Jahren geschützt.
Darum begegnet man ihnen häufig.
Ryan wird attackiert -
von einem Riesen-Drückerfisch.
Dieser verteidigt sein Revier
und kann heftig zubeissen.
Ah, das war herrlich!
Die Korallen hier waren wahnsinnig
schön, aber leider ...
Man sieht den Unterschied gut.
- Ja, ja, sehr gut, leider.
Es hat sich extrem verändert.
Es ist schlimm.
Wann passierte
das mit der Korallenbleiche?
Das erste Mal
beobachteten wir das 1998.
Eine Hauptursache
für die Korallenbleiche
ist die globale Erwärmung.
Es war auch die Folge
vom Klimawandel.
Und es wird noch häufig auftreten,
ausser
wir ändern unseren Lebensstil.
Aber die Haie sind immer noch da.
Ja, es waren fünf oder sechs.
- Sicher sechs, ja.
Sechs bis acht
Schwarzspitzen-Riffhaie.
Es war lustig, du wurdest
vom Drückerfisch angegriffen
und hinter dir waren zwei Haie,
die niemand beachtete.
Der Riesen-Drückerfisch
hat mich in die Flosse gebissen.
Er wollte sein Nest verteidigen
und Eindringlinge fernhalten.
Das sah so lustig aus.
Es war nett, wie du in meine Nähe
kamst in der Hoffnung,
dass er mich wählt:
"Nimm doch den, da ist mehr dran."
* Fliessende,
schnelle Gitarrenklänge *
Die marine Artenvielfalt
von Raja Ampat ist weltberühmt.
Über 1'400 Fischarten gibt es hier.
Die Welt unter Wasser
ist so vielfältig wie sonst kaum wo.
Zur Freude aller
tauchen auch Mantas auf.
Hier unten!
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik
begleitet von ruhigem Pfeifen *
Dort ist soeben
einer rausgesprungen.
Aber dieses Paradies ist bedroht.
Die Insel Arborek
ist innert weniger Jahre
zu einem Touristenmagnet geworden.
Das hinterlässt sichtbare Spuren.
Mit der Indonesierin Maya
hat Jonas eine Verbündete
für sein Umweltengagement gefunden.
Erinnerst du dich? Dieser Anlegesteg
war unter Tauchern der berühmteste.
Ja. Und es gab überall Fisch-
schwärme. Die sind verschwunden.
Und all die schönen Korallen ...
Alle weg.
- Alle weg.
Schau mal diese Wellen,
die grossen Boote!
Und all diese Gebäude.
Das ist Wahnsinn! Es wird brechen
und die schönen Korallen zerstören.
* Jonas spricht indonesisch. *
Jonas macht seinem Ärger Luft.
Guides und Touristen
ermahnt er zu mehr Sorgsamkeit.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Aber das Parkverbot für die Schiffe,
die Korallen zerstören,
bleibt unbeachtet.
Das ist
der Anfang des Massentourismus.
Das bedeutet mehr oder weniger
das Ende von Arborek.
Sie füttern die Fische,
und das macht das Ökosystem kaputt.
Die meisten Touristen
treten auf die Korallen.
Sie denken, es seien Steine.
Es sind aber Korallen.
Ich habe vorgeschlagen, dass ein
Posten auf dem Steg kontrolliert,
was für Boote kommen und überprüft,
ob sie die Eintrittsgebühr
bezahlt haben.
Jemand muss aufpassen,
dass niemand auf die Korallen steht
und die Boote
sollten nicht an den Steg knallen.
Es sollten nur zwei Boote
gleichzeitig hier sein
und man sollte
die Zahl der Schnorchler limitieren.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Jonas und seine Kollegin Maya
wollen eine Nichtregierungsorgani-
sation mit Einheimischen gründen.
So könnten sie mithelfen,
Raja Ampat besser zu schützen.
Das Gute daran ist:
Wir könnten wegen genau solcher
Probleme wie der Anlegestelle
zur lokalen Aufsichtsbehörde gehen
und hätten so
eine gesetzliche Basis.
Ja,
dann sind wir offiziell unterwegs.
* Sanfte Musik *
Über dem Engadin
liegt eine Schneedecke.
Beim Silsersee
ist es gerade einmal 2 °C.
Das perfekte Wetter zum Eistauchen,
finden Adelrich Uhr
und seine Tochter.
Ich ging schon oft Eistauchen,
früher schon,
und meine Tochter Tanja
macht jetzt einen Eistauchkurs.
Heute gehen wir zum ersten Mal
zusammen unter die Eisdecke.
Agi, der erfahrene Tauchinstruktor
weiss:
Eistauchen
kann man nur in der Gruppe,
alleine wäre es viel zu riskant.
Es wird sonst zu kalt,
wenn wir unter dem Eis sind.
Während Agi alle Variationen
des Tauchens liebt,
bevorzugt seine Tochter Tanja
wärmere Gewässer, die sind einfacher.
Denn Kalttauchen
ist mit viel Aufwand verbunden.
Gut, danke!
Jetzt kommt der unangenehme Teil.
Die Haare sein lassen?
- Nein, da kommt ja Wasser rein.
Ich hätte gerne einen Männerschnitt.
- Das glaube ich.
Wenn diese Härchen hier drin sind,
dringt oben Wasser ein
und verbreitet sich. Dann geht man
schnell wieder aus dem Wasser.
Das ist eine einmalige Gelegenheit.
Es ist nicht so einfach ...
Man kann nicht einfach ein Loch
in einen See bohren und abtauchen,
sondern man braucht
Sicherheitsleute,
Leute, die an der Leine sind,
an der Buddyleine,
das sehen wir alles
unten beim Loch.
* Ruhige Harmonikamusik *
Hier ist es noch viel kälter.
Doch am Polarkreis
zwischen Island und Grönland
wird es ihm warm ums Herz.
Der gefrorene Fjord ist ein Topsujet
für Robert Hansen.
Eine grandiose Kulisse, ich bin
jedes Mal einfach überwältigt.
Genau dafür ist der 52-Jährige
aus Zürich angereist.
Mir sagte mal jemand, man solle nie
den schönsten Ort verraten,
den man kennt,
sondern nur den zweitschönsten.
Das ist wirklich
einer der schönsten, die ich kenne.
Das widerspricht dem ein bisschen.
Ja, es ist ambivalent, klar.
Es gibt beide Seiten.
Man zeigt etwas Schönes, andere
werden motiviert, hierherzukommen.
Das Gute ist, es können gar nicht
so viele Leute kommen,
weil die Infrastruktur
nicht wahnsinnig gross ist.
Man muss zu Hause bleiben,
wenn man gar nichts mehr
auf der Welt anschauen will,
weil schlussendlich
alles einen Fussabdruck hinterlässt.
Wir in Westeuropa
werden immer auf der Seite stehen,
wo es mehr kaputt macht als fördert,
das ist völlig klar.
* Entspannte Musik *
Robert Hansen ist in Grönland,
in der grössten Stadt
an der Ostküste: Tasiilaq.
Gerade mal 2'000 Menschen leben hier.
Am frühen Morgen
holt ein Schneescooter
den Multimediajournalisten ab.
Die Temperatur
liegt um den Nullpunkt.
Für Robert ist das T-Shirt-Wetter.
Auf dem zugefrorenen Fjord
will er in eisige Gewässer abtauchen,
denn Robert Hansen
ist passionierter Kalttaucher.
Doch vor dem kühlen Abenteuer
wartet viel Arbeit auf ihn.
Schneeschaufeln.
Eigentlich völlig bescheuert,
weil es ziemlich viel Schnee hat.
Das mache ich zu Hause
schon nicht gerne,
und jetzt mache ich es
in den Ferien schon wieder.
* Angestrengtes Stöhnen *
Ich frage mich im Moment gerade,
weshalb ich an einem
solch absurden Ort tauchen möchte.
Der Reiz liegt natürlich
10 m weiter unten.
Aber zuerst muss man mal
dort hinkommen,
und das geht nur, wenn man
Eis und Schnee wegschaufelt.
So, da kommt die Ablösung.
Aber auch die Kollegen
tun sich mit der fast
ein Meter dicken Eisdecke schwer.
Das Problem ist,
überhaupt ein Loch graben zu können.
Wir sägen kleinere Stücke
und versuchen, die zu entfernen,
damit wir überhaupt ein Loch haben,
durch das wir ins Wasser kommen.
Dass das so dick ist,
hätte niemand gedacht.
* Entspannte Musik *
In Indonesien ist heute wieder
Freiluft-Unterricht angesagt.
Umweltlehrer Jonas Müller fährt
mit den Kindern zu einem Manta-Spot.
Hier sollen die Kinder
die beeindruckenden Meerestiere
hautnah kennenlernen.
Die Aufregung ist gross.
Bei diesem Mantaposten
müssen sich auch die Touristen
vor einem Tauchgang anmelden.
Warum wurde dieser Posten errichtet?
- Weil es viele Mantas gibt.
Ja, es gibt viele Mantas. Und?
- Damit die Mantas geschützt werden.
Ja, genau.
Darum wurde dieser Posten errichtet.
Jetzt gibt es eine Regel, dass höch-
stens 20 Taucher oder Schnorchler
gleichzeitig im Wasser sein dürfen.
Sie wissen sehr wenig
über diese Tiere.
Ich möchte ihnen Wissen vermitteln
und zeigen,
dass Mantas wundervoll
und völlig ungefährlich sind
und wie man richtig
mit ihnen umgeht.
Es hat sich bewährt:
Sobald sie beim Schnorcheln merken,
wie wundervoll diese Tiere sind,
ist die Angst weg.
Ein Mantarochen würde niemals
in euch reinschwimmen.
Er stoppt immer rechtzeitig.
Jagt ihn nicht, sondern wartet,
dann kommt er ganz nah ran.
Jeder von euch kriegt
so einen Block und einen Stift.
Damit kann man
unter Wasser schreiben.
Keine Sorge, es hat genug für alle.
Die Kinder haben
mit diesen Slades auch die Aufgabe,
zu schauen, welche Mantas sie sehen.
Also welche Spezies -
ist es ein Riff-
oder ein Riesenmanta?
Welches Geschlecht hat der Manta,
männlich oder weiblich?
Hat der Manta Verletzungen?
Sie schreiben alles auf und
achten drauf, was der Manta macht.
Isst er? Lässt er sich reinigen?
Ihre Aufgabe ist es, zu beobachten,
was der Manta macht.
Ich hoffe, dass Mantas hier sind.
Wir werden sehen,
ob wir heute Glück haben.
Die Chancen stehen gut,
denn Mantarochen und Haie
stehen hier unter Schutz.
In der eisigen Weite Grönlands
ist nur ein monotones Geräusch
zu hören.
* Kratzen des Eisbohrers *
Wir sind seit 3 Std. dran und haben
noch kein brauchbares Loch.
Ich versuche an einem anderen Ort
ein Loch zu bohren, um zu sehen,
wie dick das Eis hier ist.
Dafür, dass wir dann
30 Min. lang tauchen können,
weil es danach viel zu kalt ist,
sind Aufwand und Ertrag ...
Na ja.
Wir werden es sehen.
Ja, hier ist es genauso dick.
Ich glaube,
wir müssen an einen anderen Ort.
Bis wir hier
ein brauchbares Loch haben ...
... ist Frühling.
Am Silsersee
wird nicht lange gefackelt.
Die Motorsäge kommt zum Einsatz.
Agi und Tanja
müssen nicht selber Hand anlegen.
Der ehemalige Polizeitaucher
Urs Grigoli
öffnet das Einstiegsloch routiniert.
Wo sind die zwei Schaufeln?
Da hinten?
Siehst du?
Die kannst du runterlassen.
Das ist der Grund.
- So sehen wir es nachher unten.
So haben wir es danach unten
- Ja.
Das ist ein Sandwicheis.
Es sind
verschiedene Schichten zusammen.
Alles in allem gibt es doch
eine fast 40 cm dicke Eisschicht,
das ist nicht sehr viel.
Wir hatten schon
Schwarzeisschichten von 70 cm.
Das gibt es also auch.
Agi und Tanja machen
den obligatorischen Buddycheck.
Wie viel Bar hast du?
Ich habe 200.
180.
Tanja hat die Theorieprüfung
bereits hinter sich,
die Praxis ist für sie eine Premiere.
Mit einem Seil gesichert steigt sie
mutig als Erste ins kühle Nass.
Einmal ziehen: Du gibst mir.
Zweimal ziehen: Okay.
Dreimal ziehen:
Du ziehst uns alle raus.
Nein!
Einmal ziehen: Ich gebe.
Zweimal ziehen:
Ich nehme Leine zurück.
Und dreimal und mehrmals ziehen
ist ein Notzeichen,
und dann kommt der Standby-Taucher.
- Okay.
* Entspannte,
perlende Gitarrenklänge *
Nicht nur in Indonesien,
sondern auch auf den Seychellen
leben viele Mantas.
Mit ihnen zu tauchen,
ist für die Meeresbiologin
Ornella Weideli ein Highlight.
Die 32-Jährige macht Belly Shots,
Fotos vom Bauch der Tiere,
denn jeder ist anders.
Diese Fotos helfen, die Wanderung
der Tiere nachzuvollziehen.
Es sind gigantische Tiere.
Bei einem Erwachsenen
kann die Spannweite der Brustflossen
bis zu 7 m betragen.
Mantas sind friedlich
und ernähren sich von Plankton
und kleinen Fischen,
die sie in Küstennähe finden.
Ornella und Kollege Michael
sind begeistert.
Super!
Wir haben versucht,
möglichst viele Belly Shots,
also Bauchfotos zu machen.
Es ist immer das Beste,
wenn man unter den Mantas ist,
sie über einen durchschwimmen
und das Licht langsam tiefer kommt.
Unter Wasser sind sie so elegant.
Sie tanzen einfach so ...
... um dich herum,
das ist wunderschön.
Die habe ich mitgenommen, weil ...
Weil du durstig bist.
- Nein nicht ganz.
Ich schwamm auf der Oberfläche,
der Manta ist gekommen,
und die Flasche war so vor ihm.
Würde die in seinem Mund landen,
wäre das nicht so gut.
Also habe ich sie mitgenommen.
Weltweit schwimmen in den Ozeanen
an die 90 Mio. t Plastik,
Müll,
der für die tierischen Meeresbewohner
zu einer tödlichen Mahlzeit
werden kann.
* Sanfte Musik *
In Grönlands wird den Eistauchern
auf dem zugefrorenen Fjord
nichts geschenkt.
Noch immer wird hart
für das Einstiegsloch gearbeitet.
Salzwasser würde eine Motorsäge
sofort zerstören.
Wie lange sägen wir schon?
Etwa 4, 5 Std.
Ich hatte mir schon vorgestellt,
dass es anstrengend würde.
Das kann einem auch auf einem
Schweizer Bergsee passieren.
Aber das ist schon extrem,
wenn man erst noch 80, 90 cm
dickes Eis durchsägen muss.
Das ist schon ... ja.
(Angestrengt) Ja!
Dann endlich bewegt sich etwas.
Das schaffst du alleine.
Willst du den hier?
- Ja, voll!
Wir haben's.
- Ab ins Wasser!
Es ist geschafft.
Die Unterwasserwelt steht offen.
* Entspannte Musik,
Geräusch des Atemgeräts *
Eisstrukturen
mit eingeschlossenen Luftblasen.
So sieht die Welt unter Wasser
im Oberengadiner Silsersee aus.
Das Licht,
das durch das Eis schimmert,
verleiht der Szenerie
etwas Entrücktes.
Dann stellt Agi
die Eiswelt auf den Kopf.
Sieht einfach aus,
ist aber nur für geübte Taucher.
Er wird dann
irgendwann mal zurückkommen,
weil er keine Leine mehr kriegt.
Jetzt machen sie sowieso Patchwork
mit der Leine, stelle ich fest.
Tanja verzichtet
auf solche Kapriolen.
Dann, nach 20 Min.,
dringt die Kälte des Wassers
durch den Anzug und sie tauchen auf.
Vater und Tochter haben
den ersten gemeinsamen Eistauchgang
unbeschadet überstanden.
Es war super. Mega schön.
Herrlich, herrlich!
Wie immer beim Eistauchen.
Wunderschön. Wir sind ca. 30 m
unter der Eisfläche
in Richtung See geschwommen.
Wir sahen dort die Fischer,
wollten ihnen einen Fisch stehlen,
aber wir sahen selber keinen.
Nein, es war herrlich, nicht wahr?
Ja, es war sehr schön,
so der Eisfläche entlang.
V.a. mit der Luft
sah es sehr toll aus.
Der erfahrene Tauchinstruktor
stellt seiner Tochter
ein gutes Zeugnis aus:
Es war wahnsinnig: Sie zeigte
keine Angst, sie atmete ruhig,
der Lungenautomat kann nicht
vereisen, wenn man so ruhig atmet,
er kann nicht abblasen.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf meine Toch-
ter, dass das so gut geklappt hat.
Prost -
auf den erfolgreichen Eistauchgang.
Prost!
Tanja, gratuliere dir herzlich zum
Diplom, zum bestandenen Eistauchen.
Hier habe ich noch
ein Diplom für dich.- Danke.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
ob ich es einrahme und aufhänge.
Ich habe jetzt so viele Diplome.
Aber, ja ...
Ich werde es sicher
zu Hause aufstellen.
Lochen und in den Ordner.
- In den Ordner.
Hier verlassen wir Agi und Tanja.
Dass seine Tochter
dieselbe Leidenschaft
für die Welt unter Wasser hat wie er,
ist für den Vater
eine grosse Genugtuung.
In Grönland brennt Robert Hansen
seit Stunden darauf,
in die arktischen Gewässer
einzutauchen.
Schön warm, schön warm eingepackt,
jetzt kann es losgehen.
Über Wasser ist es 0 °C,
unter Wasser -3 °C.
Selbst für Hartgesottene
ist das eine Herausforderung.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Sonnenstrahlen,
die durch das Einstiegsloch dringen,
zaubern eine sakrale Atmosphäre.
Die Sicht ist perfekt und klar
bis 40 m.
Robert Hansen scheint zu schweben,
entrückt in einer ganz eigenen Welt.
Mit seiner Kamera hält Robert das
vielfältige Leben unter Wasser fest:
farbige Riffe und kleine Garnelen.
Im Licht der Tauchlampen
leuchten bunte Anemonen.
Ein Skorpionfisch beobachtet ihn.
Und blütenartige Schnecken
verblüffen den Betrachter.
* Sphärische Klänge, Blubbern *
Hier unten vergisst Robert
Zeit und Raum.
Erst nach einer geschlagenen Stunde
gibt Robert Hansen der Kälte nach
und taucht auf.
Die ersten 40 Min. lief es super.
Am Ende kriegte ich merkwürdiger-
weise kalte Oberschenkel.
Den Zehen geht es relativ gut,
die Finger sind langsam etwas
eingefroren, aber es ist aushaltbar.
Es ist schon am Limit, ja.
Boah!
Diese Hand ist eingefroren,
dieser geht es super.
Mein Mund ist eingefroren,
aber es macht nichts, wenn ich
nicht so viel sprechen kann.
Im angenehm warmen Wasser
von Raja Ampat
machen sich die Kinder
auf die Suche nach Mantas,
vor denen sie grossen Respekt haben.
Aber erst einmal
sehen sie v.a. Plastik.
Aus dem Unterricht von Jonas
wissen sie,
dass die Tiere ihn fressen
und daran eingehen können.
Darum sammeln ihn die Kinder ein.
Weiter unten entdecken sie
gleich mehrere Mantarochen.
Schnell weicht die Zurückhaltung
der Faszination.
Im wohl exotischsten Klassenzimmer
der Welt
lernen sie diese neugierigen Tiere
hautnah kennen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Die Kinder
haben ihre Angst überwunden,
und es besteht die Hoffnung,
dass sie später mithelfen werden,
diese einzigartigen Tiere
zu schützen.
Auf den Seychellen sorgen Delfine
bei Ornella Weideli für Hochstimmung.
* Jubel *
* Dynamische Klänge *
Das Forschungsteam ist auf der Suche
nach solchen
grünen Meeresschildkröten.
Ryan Daly,
der lokale wissenschaftliche Leiter
der Stiftung Save Our Seas,
ist auf sie spezialisiert.
Entwischt.
Da ist noch eine, direkt vor dir.
Siehst du sie?
Yeah.
Wir haben alles dabei,
um Schildkröten zu fangen.
Ryan hält vom Bug des Bootes
Ausschau
nach grünen Meeresschildkröten.
Darnsley koordiniert.
Er sagt ihm, wo, wie, was,
und Darnsley manövriert hier durch.
Klingt einfach ...
Zu schnell.
... ist aber ziemlich schwierig.
Sie ahnte, da kommt was.
Yes!
Er hat sie.
Eine grüne Meeresschildkröte.
Sie wurde noch nicht markiert.
Wir bringen sie jetzt zum Ufer,
um sie zu vermessen.
Vorsicht, sie schlägt aus!
Leg sie kopfvoran vor dich hin!
Wir beobachten die brütenden Tiere.
Die sind am einfachsten,
weil sie an Land kommen.
Über die jungen Schildkröten
wissen wir weniger,
die sind schwieriger zu fangen.
Darum fangen wir sie so.
Sie sind ein wichtiger Teil
der Schildkrötenpopulation,
über die wir nicht viel wissen.
Das Saint-Joseph-Atoll
ist sehr wichtig für die Futtersuche
und den Schutz der Tiere.
Es hat sich ausbezahlt,
dass hier schon vor vielen Jahren
ein Schutzprojekt für Meeres
schildkröten eingerichtet wurde.
Ist das Datenblatt hier drin?
Ja, da drin.
Die grüne Meeresschildkröte
stammt von der Landschildkröte ab
und existiert seit 225 Mio. Jahren.
Sie atmen Luft.
Sie müssen nicht unter Wasser sein.
Ihnen ist auch
über Wasser sehr wohl.
Benutzt du dieses Ding?
- Wir brauchen das kleinere.
Das hier?
- Ja.
Wir markieren nun die Schildkröten.
Wenn wir sie erneut fangen, gibt uns
das Hinweise über die Anzahl Tiere.
Bis bald!
Wir fangen eine Schildkröte
kaum je zweimal.
D.h., es gibt hier
eine grosse Population.
Gemäss Schätzungen leben ungefähr
2'000 grüne Meeresschildkröten
im Saint-Joseph-Atoll.
Auch für die erwachsenen Tiere
ist es wichtig,
weil sie an den Stränden
Eier ablegen.
Es gibt nicht viele Orte,
wo wir erwachsene, nistende Tiere
und gleichzeitig Jungtiere haben,
die hier leben.
Es ist ein einzigartiger Platz
für grüne Meeresschildkröten
im Indischen Ozean.
Der Schutz der Tiere und der Umwelt -
danach richtet Ornella ihre Arbeit,
aber auch ihr Leben aus.
Ich fliege z.B. sehr viel
und ich weiss,
dass das schlecht ist
für den ökologischen Fussabdruck.
Aber wenn jeder ändert, was er kann,
gehen wir alle
einen Schritt vorwärts.
Man kann nicht alles radikal ändern.
Ich kann nicht aufhören, zu reisen.
Das gehört zu meiner Arbeit.
Dafür schränke ich mich sehr ein,
wenn es um meine Ernährung geht.
Das Ziel ist,
dass sich jeder etwas einschränkt.
Für die Bernerin geht die Zeit
auf den Seychellen dem Ende entgegen.
Bis im Frühling
will sie ihre Doktorarbeit
über das Verhalten der Junghaie
im Staint-Joseph-Atoll beenden.
Was dann kommt, ist noch offen.
Es würde mich sehr freuen
und stark motivieren,
wenn ich etwas zum Schutz der Haie
beitragen könnte.
Natürlich kann ich nicht
alle Haie schützen,
aber vielleicht eine Art,
an einem Ort.
Hier in Saint Joseph
haben wir das Glück,
dass sie hoffentlich
bald geschützt werden.
Aber an anderen Orten
sind die Haie sehr stark gefährdet,
z.B. in Gebieten,
wo die Jungen geboren werden.
Ich könnte mithelfen,
dass sie dort geschützt sind.
Wenn ich alt bin,
kann ich zurückschauen und sagen:
"Hier konnte ich mithelfen."
Ich will etwas Grosses erreichen.
Einen 8-bis-17-Uhr-Job
könnte ich sowieso nie machen.
Und persönlich ...
Ich will einfach glücklich sein,
ganz einfach.
Ornella lebt den Moment.
Und sie lebt ihren Traum.
Eine Haiforscherin
aus einem Land ohne Meer.
Sie hatte den Mut,
nach den Sternen zu greifen.
In Tasiilaq hofft Robert Hansen
auf den Tauchgang seines Lebens.
Denn dieser Eisberg erwärmt
das Herz des Kalttauchers.
Flut und Ebbe heben und senken
das Wasser mit dem Eis um den Berg.
Allein das ist ein Spektakel.
Dieses Mal
ist das Eis beim Einstiegsloch dünn,
anders als beim letzten Mal,
wo sich die Eisschichten entlang
des Ufers übereinander gelegt hatten.
Aber auch so
ist der Eistaucher gefordert.
40 kg Gepäck am Rücken,
ein schwerer Rucksack.
Robert weiss aber auch um
die Vergänglichkeit dieser Eiswelt.
Die Folgen des Klimawandels
werden immer deutlicher.
Das bestätigt auch
Expeditionsleiter Sven Gust.
Man sieht schon,
dass die Gletscher in erschreckender
Geschwindigkeit abschmelzen.
Die Auswirkungen davon
lassen noch etwas auf sich warten,
aber wir sehen tatsächlich,
dass Tierarten hier zu finden sind -
z.B. Pottwale und Pilotwale -,
die wir früher
gar nicht gesichtet haben.
Die sind jetzt im Sommer
Normalität geworden.
Das hat sich innerhalb
der zehn Jahre,
in denen ich diese Gegend
jetzt kenne, schon sehr verändert.
Es ist besser,
wenn du es andersrum drehst.
Robert taucht ein
ins eisig kalte Wasser.
Die Temperatur beträgt -3 °C.
Das Salz verhindert,
dass das Wasser einfriert.
Der Eisberg
gleicht einer gewaltigen Skulptur.
* Sphärische Klänge,
Geräusch des Atemgeräts *
Mal sind die Konturen weich und rund.
Dann wieder sind Kanten messerscharf.
Robert kann den Eisberg
auskundschaften -
bis in 20 m Tiefe.
Im nährstoffreichen Wasser
gedeihen viele Pflanzen.
Die braunen Kelp-Blätter
beherbergen auch Skorpionfische.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Diese Eiszapfen
haben sich über Wasser gebildet.
Die Flut
hat sie unter Wasser gesetzt.
Der Fotograf ist in seinem Element.
Aber nach 75 Min. bei -3 °C
ist endgültig Schluss.
Robert muss auftauchen.
Robert hat schon
über 500 Tauchgänge gemacht.
Aber dieser wird ihm wohl für immer
in Erinnerung bleiben.
Das werde ich nie mehr so erleben.
Das war so schön.
Es war einfach magisch.
* Zufriedenes Ausatmen *
* Ausatmen *
Und am Schluss der Sonnenstrahl,
der da reingeschienen hat, so schön.
So schön.
Vielleicht sind es
solche überwältigende Momente,
die uns Menschen Demut lehren
und uns daran erinnern,
Sorge zu tragen zur einzigen Erde,
die wir haben.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Beim Mantaspot in Raja Ampat
geniessen Jonas und die Kinder
den abenteuerlichen Unterricht.
Die Mantas haben sie
aus nächster Nähe erlebt.
Wir hatten drei Mantas,
viele Taucher,
aber leider auch viel Abfall.
Es war bestimmt eine coole Erfahrung
für die Kids,
mit den Mantas zusammen
zu schnorcheln.
Sie sind sehr begeistert davon, ja.
Das haben wir
beim Schnorcheln rausgeholt,
und das ist natürlich genau ...
Die Mantas ernähren sich dort unten.
Das Plastik
löst sich in Mikroplastik auf,
welches die Mantas
dann fälschlicherweise auch essen.
Die Exkursion war ein voller Erfolg.
Die Kinder werden das Gelernte
nicht so schnell vergessen.
Edy hat z.B. aufgeschrieben:
"Das waren Riffmantas."
Also keine Riesenmantas,
das stimmt.
Das waren alles Riffmantas. Es gibt
ja zwei verschiedene Spezies.
Das hat er richtig erkannt.
Und er hat gesehen, dass eine der
Flossen der Mantas angebissen war.
Auch das ist richtig.
Die angebissene Flosse
war eine von mehreren Verletzungen.
So hat jedes Kind aufgeschrieben,
was ihm aufgefallen ist.
Und das haben sie super gemacht.
Aufgabe sehr gut erfüllt.
Melando, wie viele Mantarochen
hast du gesehen?
Drei.
Hat jemand mehr gesehen?
- (Kinder) Nein.
Hat jemand weniger gesehen?
Also alle drei.
- (Kinder) Ja.
Sie freuten sich sehr,
die Mantas zu sehen.
Sie haben jetzt
keine Angst mehr vor ihnen -
zumindest sagen sie das.
Ob es tatsächlich so ist,
wird sich zeigen,
wenn wir
wieder einmal Mantas antreffen.
Es ist super.
Wenn wir so weitermachen,
sehen sie mehr und mehr
die Schönheiten.
Und wer die Schönheit
von etwas erkennt,
ist eher bereit,
zum Schutz beizutragen.
Wie haben dir die Mantas gefallen?
- Schön.
Glücklich?
- Ja.
Happy?
Man merkt es,
er strahlt übers ganze Gesicht.
* Entspannte Musik *
Man darf nicht meinen,
man könne die Welt retten oder so,
aber ich kann den Kindern
viel mitgeben.
Ich möchte, dass sie
mit dem Verständnis aufwachsen,
dass sie eines Tages die richtige
Hebel für Raja Ampat ziehen können.
Das ist mein täglicher Antrieb.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Claudia Burri - 2018